it's the hoax case that's drawing
comparison to Jesse Smollett police are
now said to be weighing criminal charges
against Alabama woman Carly Russell
after she admitted to faking her own
kidnapping the 25 year old disappeared
Without a Trace after making a chilly
9-1-1 phone call claiming that she saw a
toddler wandering alone on a highway it
sent police on a wild goose chase
launching a nationwide effort to find
her that was until 48 hours later when
she turned up safe at her parents home
with a wild story Harley Russell said
that she had been kidnapped and
physically fought for her life but it
wasn't long before the story unraveled
police reading this statement from her
lawyer
there was no kidnapping on Thursday July
9th 13th 2023.
my client did not see a baby on the side
of the road
my client did not leave the Hoover area
which was identified as a missing person
my client did not have any help in this
incident
but this was a single act done by
herself
my client was not with anyone or any
hotel with anyone from the time she was
missing
police now sharing some of the damning
Google Searchers that Russell made in
the days leading up to the hoax so
things like this do you need to pay for
Amber Alert how to take money from
register without being caught bus
tickets and the movie Taken Russell's
hoax story also fooling her very worried
parents who spoke out in an emotional
interview shortly after she returned
home
there were moments when she physically
had to fight for her life and there were
moments when she had to mentally fight
for her life
but she made it back to you she made it
back do you believe that there was an
abductor still out there
absolutely
Greg in the year of Our Lord 2023 do not
try to fake your own kidnapping I
thought about you're gonna get caught
yeah you know she's no but I gotta say
this is not like Jesse Smollett she was
an out to cause some kind of racial
political right right this and I think
you're not going to get a deep
Revelation out of this she just wanted
to feel special she wanted to feel loved
don't we all uh if you start at the
beginning of a story like this you got
370 million people a lot of weird stuff
goes on in this world right social media
and smartphones has Amplified the
weirdness I have a feeling that this
probably happened before in the 1950s
but it was handled privately a girl
would stay out late she'd get scared and
tell her parents that she was kidnapped
and then the police would come and then
they'd be like forget about it then it
changed with Tawana Brawley right that
was brought to you by the media and
exploited by certain charlatans who are
still around right now often on MSNBC it
became incentivized we haven't built a
world I think a world of of
demonic incentives a destructive need
for attention which is now married to
impact so you no longer have people
attempting suicide but mass shootings
which are basically suicide plus uh if
you find no meaning in the world infamy
takes its place and uh we didn't think
of that when we canceled Christ judge
should she be charged and have to pay a
penalty because it the police spent a
lot of resources to try to find this
missing toddler to try to find her
um there is no doubt in my mind that I
would charge her when you have all of
the uh all of the police hours that were
invested into this case when they could
have been doing other cases cold cases
uh and that when you have that backdrop
on all those facts that indicate that
you know she was staging this whole
thing it's pretty clear that you know
for whatever reason she needed to do
this I spoke to the chief assistant D.A
in the uh in the DA's office and without
saying whether or not they will or will
not go forward you know the charges are
basically filing a false report it's a
misdemeanor there are two separate
misdemeanors that can be filed uh the
most that they can serve is uh 12 months
on a Class A misdemeanor but what I
think is important to note here it's not
just the wasted man hours there was a
woman whose daughter was abducted and
the child the child was killed that
woman led the voluntary search effort
can you imagine the trauma that she went
through because this woman needed some
tension and there were 43 children
missing in Alabama today when they say
that there's a child filed along the
road every one of those parents or or
protectors must be thinking it could be
mine it could be mine so I don't have
much Mercy for this woman I really don't
she should be convicted uh she should
have to pay restitution for the hours
that were invested in this case sound
fair Jessica it does to me I obviously
don't have the legal expertise in this
but I would just add what you've done to
your parents who are now have been
paraded out on TV gone on The Today Show
defending you as any parent would right
Cleo God forbid came back and told me
that story I would have the exact same
reaction that that mother did
um and that's another level of Twisted
to all of this
um to that that's a good I have a point
that like oh thank you no because like
we never follow these stories because we
know they're going to fall apart they we
always know we know we were sitting in
the Green Room during the smallest thing
this thing isn't going to last this
thing we knew was faked but you can't
but then the NBC go always incentivizes
these things too early but it is new it
is an important news story if there are
43 missing kids and there's nothing and
maybe you know it's all the estrogen and
the mommy stuff coursing through me when
I hear about a missing child yeah or
something like that immediately
heartstrings have been pulled so hard
and you want to know more so I don't
fault there was also money involved
Crime Stoppers offered five thousand
dollar reward an anonymous donor kicked
in 25 000 and 60 other concerned
citizens donated money and made that
total rise to over sixty three thousand
dollars ooh Jesse oh figure that out
I had some red flags from the very
beginning when she blamed the white man
with orange hair yeah it's called red
hair yeah Carrot Top was nowhere near
right and you know white people have
been blaming black people for fake
crimes for quite some time oh there's
two black guys over there you know what
she blamed the white guy we're even okay
I looked up where I 459 is in Alabama
There's a baby with a diaper this is a
freeway there is no way a baby is
walking down this highway then she says
the
orange-haired white man
stumbled out of the trees to check on
the baby and then brought her over a
fence into the woods okay he has no
weapon how is a strange white man
bringing this person over a fence anyway
and what happened to the baby the white
guy just leave the baby that makes no
sense then she says she was taken into a
back of an 18 wheeler truck and she
heard a female voice but she couldn't
see the female an 18-wheeler cab is
about that bit you're going to be able
to see the woman in there and then they
said they tied her hands up like this
and they took pictures of her naked now
you can go online and you can see
pictures of people naked why are you
just going to tie someone up take
pictures and not do anything and she
said they did nothing else yeah they did
nothing else okay that makes no sense
all right and then they said they didn't
tie her up actually because they didn't
want to leave compression marks on the
rest because you know when I kidnap
people that is the first thing I think
don't leave compression marks okay the
best part of it she came home with just
her right sock on and she had 107
dollars in it
well hopefully she gets the help that
she needs yeah
that's what you forgot to say yeah
she has to pay for these things that she
caused okay
coming up a self-proclaimed Debbie
Downer Doc is trying to ruin going to
the movies I went on Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now